bonsoir pierre berthelot merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
loeb boycott des produits français
finalement pourrait se retourner contre
contre la turquie
oui vous l'avez bien rappeler dans le
reportage
il ya un effet boomerang potentiel
puisque ces produits sont effectivement
en grande partie fabriqués en turquie
on aurait pu citer peut-être le meilleur
exemple est celui des automobiles
renault
donc on sait qu'il ya une grande usine
présentant en turquie donc là aussi il
est clair que si ces automobiles ne sont
plus achetés par les turcs
même si elles ont vocation aussi à être
exporté de toute façon et dans tous les
cas de figure ce sera une perte pour
l'économie tout ce qu il faut bien
saisir c'est que chez erdogan
il ya toujours une partie de rhétorique
qui est très importante mais derrière
les actes ne suivent pas forcément un
autre exemple intéressant c'est la
relation avec israël
donc on sait que la turquie se veut un
peu le champion de la cause islamique ou
encore de des droits des palestiniens
puisque cette cause a été plus ou moins
abandonnée par d'autres pays arabes
sauf que là aussi derrière la rhétorique
anti israélienne
il n'y a pas forcément toujours les
actes qui suivent c'est à dire une
rupture franche avec l'état hébreu donc
là c'est un peu la même chose je pense
que erdogan s'est dit à une occasion
pour lui de se refaire une santé
politique puisqu'il est même contesté
dans son propre pays
et puis parce qu'il peut toujours se
poser en chef de file du monde musulman
d'une certaine manière il ya une place à
prendre parce que j'ai expliqué qu'il ya
un espèce de vide arabe mais pour autant
est-ce que ce boycott va être durable
est ce que réellement les turcs ne vont
pas faire la part des choses
on pense notamment à cette population
turque au style alerte au gaz qui
représente à peu près 50% de la
population donc peut-être que l à la
limite va faire le contraire de ce que
dira dogan justement pour le mettre en
difficulté
un mot sur l'interview qu'a accordé
manuel macron
à la chaîne al jazira chaîne du qatar
proche des frères musulmans ont c est ce
que pour vous c'est c'était une bonne
idée de le faire oui je pense tout ce
qui va dans la décrispation détention la
diminution des tensions est une bonne
chose il faut éviter de mettre de
l'huile sur le feu comme certains sont
tentés de le faire on a vu des hommes
politiques français actuels ou anciens
d'ailleurs je pense à manuel valls qui
appelait à montrer les caricatures dès
la rentrée à tous les élèves
voilà sans qu'ils aient véritablement un
débat préparatoire
ça me semble assez dangereux donc tout
ce qui va dans le sens de calmer les
tensions
effectivement est une bonne chose même
si l'équilibré difficile parce
qu'effectivement emmanuel macron est
aussi le président du pays des droits de
l'homme de la liberté absolue de
critiquer dewar de blasphémer donc les
ailes à l'exercice et est compliquée
mais s'il fait ce premier pas c'est une
bonne chose de même que la france a
tendu la main à la turquie suite
récemment au tremblement de terre donc
tout ce qui va dans le sens de calmer le
jeu
c'est une bonne chose encore une fois je
le répète il faut distinguer la lutte
antiterroriste et la question de la
présence de la gestion d'une communauté
musulmane importante en france ces deux
choses qui sont différentes et si on
fait l'amalgamé alors on pas toujours
vers plus de tension vers plus de
conflits et vers plus de risque et de
danger
n'y at il pas eu quand même une
maladresse de la part d' emmanuel macron
dans son discours sur le séparatisme on
s'est parlé de l'islam de france mais
également il a élargi ce problème à l
islam en général dans le monde
ces deux visions finalement qui ne se
comprennent pas les musulmans qui se
disent offensé ne comprennent pas ce que
ça peut être la laïcité en france par
exemple déjà effectivement il ya sur le
séparatisme une maladresse
parce que d'abord comme l'ont souligné
certains spécialistes de la part des
islamistes les plus radicaux les plus
militants il n'ya pas une volonté de se
séparer de créer un territoire
la france alors leur but c'est plutôt au
contraire gagné en influence dans toutes
les strates de la société française
deuxièmement on a d'emblée exclu les
mouvements séparatistes qui eux existent
en france
on peut penser à des mouvements qui
existent en corse ou de façon plus
discrète dans d'autres régions
françaises
pourquoi d'emblée on les a exclus ce
c'est le piège dans lequel on est tombé
puisque c'est effectivement on en est
revenu à faire une loi sur les
séparatistes qui vise une certaine
manière les musulmans et d'ailleurs on
voit que le gouvernement n'est pas
claire sur le sujet parce qu'au départ
il a parlé de loi sur séparatisme et
puis il semble avoir fait un pas en
arrière dans un premier temps en disant
finalement ce sera une loi sur la
laïcité donc au plus haut niveau de
l'état on voit bien qu'il ya deux lignes
qui s'opposent et on ne sait pas trop
qui va alors porté aujourd'hui est-ce
que c'est lalique la ligne laïque je
peux dire extrême est très conservatrice
ou est ce que c'est la ligne finalement
macron celle qu'il avait présenté lors
de la campagne présidentielle où il
semblait plutôt vouloir une laïcité
certes strict mais néanmoins ouverte et
souple voilà donc aujourd'hui où on en
est donc on attend des clarifications et
est-ce que suite aux attentats qui
viennent de se passer on va pas revenir
au projet initial avec le mot
séparatisme donc on attend une
clarification de la part des autres des
plus hautes autorités françaises donc un
boycott qui n'aurait pas beaucoup de
conséquences économiques
c'est je crois que 2% des des
exportations en turquie concernant
ce qui pourrait être dommageable pour la
france or sur le plan politique et
sécuritaire en tout cas des mots qui ont
fait mal oui enfin des mots qui sont pas
compris par sont encore une fois le
concept de laïcité à la française n'est
pas saisie et on le voit bien par
exemple dans un pays comme le canada
puisque le premier ministre monsieur
trudeau a rappelé que lui n'était pas
sur la position de macron et pourtant le
canada est un pays laïc puisqu'il n'ya
pas de religion d'état et que aussi au
canada on a le droit de critiquer les
religions de dire que l'on préfère telle
religion à une autre qu'elle est
meilleure mais effectivement ça ne se
fait pas de la même manière qu'en france
avec ce côté un petit peu caricatural
justement qui incarne qu'incarne
certaine presse donc ça c'est un
problème le deuxième élément vous dit le
boycott
oui peut-être que sur la turquie il n'y
a pas que la turquie hidayat tout le
monde arabe et musulman
donc là aussi il faut attendre pour voir
quelles vont être les conséquences je
pense si on arrive à calmer le jeu dans
les semaines qui viennent ce sera oublié
dans quelques mois si on persiste
effectivement sur un projet qui est un
peu floue et qui suscite de l'amertume
de l'incompréhension en france alors ça
peut être dangereux
moi mon inquiétude c'est par exemple sur
les grands contrats les grands contrats
avec les grandes entreprises
là c'était contre ans où on s'est
souvent d'état à état
dans ce cas là il ya une menace et puis
qui va prendre effectivement les parts
de marché de la france dans ces pays là
bas ce sera souvent des pays comme les
etats unis ou leurs alliés donc c'est
pas forcément une bonne chose d'où le
sentiment qu'on est un peu dans un piège
qui nous est tendu par certains
effectivement qui se veulent les héros
de la laci la laïcité mais qui sont dans
le même temps souvent des
néoconservateurs américains en tout cas
qui était partisan de la guerre en irak
qui sont pour une modification de la
position de la france au proche orient
qui devrait finalement entrer dans le
rang et ne pas avoir cette position
gaulliste traditionnel déquilibre il
faut faire attention à tout sept
personnes qui veulent parfois un peu
manipulé l'opinion ou même les
dirigeants au plus haut niveau de l'état
il faut les écouter il faut les
respecter mais ne pas leur donner
peut-être plus d'importance qu'il n'en
non mais c'est vrai qu'on voit c'est
ces photos en tout cas d' emmanuel
macron brûlés dans la rue ça rappelle
d'ailleurs les portraits de george bush
lors de la guerre en irak en 2003
lorsque c'est ces images étaient
également brûlés ou piétinés par par
certains pays arabes
on vous parlait de du canada c'est vrai
qu'on entend pas beaucoup les alliés de
la france en tout cas ce sujet c'est un
sujet ultrasensible c'est un sujet
sensible parce qu'effectivement ces
états soit ont des relations avec des
pays musulmans qui souhaitent conserver
soit parce qu'ils ont eux mêmes leur
propre communauté musulmane ils veulent
pas créer finalement un problème
inutile et puis il y en a certains qui
sont pas mécontents de voir la position
de la france affaiblit puisque je le
rappelle finalement aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'on a on a les pays de l'alliance
atlantique ont en tout cas de lax pro
américain puis de l'autre vous avez là
ce qu'on appelle les pays émergents qui
sont qui contestent la ligne américaine
ou celle de leurs alliés et puis vous
avez des pays qui tentent d'avoir une
position originale de se distinguer ce
qui est le cas de la france où ce qu'il
a été pendant longtemps
donc ils sont pas mécontent de la voir
en difficulté et finalement c'est ce qui
se passe dans un certain nombre de pays
puisque si vous prenez le cas du liban
c'est intéressant de voir que
paradoxalement les états unis sont
beaucoup plus critiques et au liban que
la france qui a été accueilli récemment
par emmanuel macron mais au final qui a
réussi une percée diplomatique récemment
c les etats unis puisque l'on sait que
le liban et israël discutent des
frontières maritimes à propos des
gisements de gaz potentielles donc voilà
c'est vraiment il ya encore une fois je
répète il ya un piège qui est tendue à
la france j'espère qu'avec la france
qu'emmanuel mal qu'on sera assez habile
pour ne pas tomber dans ce piège de ceux
qui souhaitent effectivement une
stratégie de tension voilà une stratégie
de tension qui au final n'apportera rien
à la france ni à l'extérieur ni au plan
intérieur donc il faut effectivement
trouvé un discours de raison
retrouver la raison et avoir un discours
très ferme par rapport aux terroristes
on
comprends pas pourquoi un certain nombre
d'entre eux des personnes qui sont
fichés est ce qu'ils ne sont même pas de
nation française voire qui ont été
condamnés pour 10 à 10 pourquoi est-ce
qu'elles sont encore sur le territoire
français et puis de l'autre
effectivement cette tension cette
stratégie qui stigmatise à tort ou à
raison une partie de la population
française donc il faut bien distinguer
les deux qu'on commence par déjà exécuté
les lois et les décisions qui sont
prises par les juges lorsqu'elles le
sont avant de créer de nouvelles lois
voilà donc ça c'est deux choses bien
différentes la lutte antiterroriste et
les questions de société laïcité est
donc en mélangeant tout retombe dans un
amalgame
merci beaucoup pierre berthelot d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions sur rt
france